i had had some self-reflection recently
about
what my sticking power
is or isn't going to be
what do you mean by sticking power
uh my
personal concern about my risk of
slipping backwards into blue pill when
it comes to
you know getting back out there and and
and whatnot and so i had this reflection
of what you know how how successful am i
going to be at holding the line and not
falling back into that into that frame
and so
that led me down a path of thinking
about
how different
people respond and how different
different paths that people take
after they become red pill aware right
and so i think some of them we know
right some of them some people take
the darker approach and they go to mgtow
some of them
you know just use it as a tool to ramp
up their ability to slay
and then i think a lot of people at some
point have to find some space in between
those two extremes
of figuring out how do they use red pill
to serve them in the best way possible
and so
yeah the question of what what are the
different paths that people end up
taking and and why did they take it and
how is it even potentially related to
the way they came to be red pill aware
was it a violent awareness that was
thrust upon them was it a slow
sort of thing and then you know you've
been thinking about to a degree
uh i've got a son
and i was reflecting to a buddy of mine
you know
i didn't have anyone teaching me these
lessons i had to come to it after 35
plus years on my own and figure it out
through trial and error
and which is what red pill is right it
was a bunch of guys doing trial and
error and sharing notes and figuring
out but even thinking about
what brings you to red pill what past do
you take from red pill
how are those two things connected
and i'm sure you've seen ranch a lot of
trends over the years of people coming
to red pill and the different paths they
take and i can imagine you probably can
think of some people that
kind of entered into the space and then
you know ghosted fell off for whatever
and then others that have stuck around
and
they've integrated it to the degree that
they you know it serves them but um yeah
so that was a high level topic with that
little nuance of humble i might have a
little worry about my ability to stick
with it i've got a little self-doubt
yeah i think a lot of people um not just
you have the self-doubt and revert back
to their old ways you know the
comforting lies
um
so
setting aside that's it you just hit the
the key word the comforting lies right
yeah yeah
it's brutal it's honest it is because
it's because they're because it's a
collection of uncomfortable truths right
and
it's not comfortable knowing that a
woman is never going to love you
unconditionally right it's it's it's
it's highly unlikely i mean sure there's
some exceptions you know perhaps there's
probably guys um you know that'll watch
this at some point you know over the
next few weeks and say something in the
comments like i've been married for 82
years and i went bankrupt 17 times and
lost my job 32 and
you know my wife stuck with me through
everything
that's true you know like i've seen
those comments too but
the
the cold hard truths that come with it
with the unplugging are
you know it's like that whole jagged
pill like once you swallow you can't
spit it back up sort of thing i mean you
know you can try you know you can you
can try and go back to your old ways and
that's usually when
guys sort of like blend you know the two
versions of being plugged into
comforting lies and unplugging from the
comforting lies and seeing the cold hard
truth you know they call it the purple
pill in the pillow world because it kind
of blends the two colors
i hadn't heard a purple pill before yeah
it it's it's kind of like an a la carte
it's like you know i'm gonna take some
of this that i like over here with the
cold hartruce and i'm gonna take some of
these comforting lies over here because
you know like i really like them and
kind of blend it up and i'm gonna serve
myself this dish of you know
uh
and truce you know kind of
together right yeah but well you're also
your point there and somebody else
mentioned this in the
in the chat group that this
came up a bit
you can never turn off your awareness
right there is no
it's not life after red pill as if it's
gone away it's just
life after red pill awareness right
because that awareness is ingrained it's
there and if you slip back to the
comforting lies
um you still know
underneath
that
it's phony that there's you know that
that risk
uh is do they though because i mean like
how many guys do you know that that
that have been married they've been
through the grinder they got divorced
they lost you know lost half the world
they have limited access to their kids
you know you have a conversation with
them over a beer or a meeting or an
event or something like that they're
like i'm never getting married again and
then a year or two later he's living
with a chick and he's married again
right hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you